yeah roots above the sea it's not yeah
the whole point was if we can buy what
we know about calculus and the roots of
a polynomial right that can break a lot
public down besides okay so we took your
findings in fact that you like oh I've
got a double root that means I know
something have stationary points its own
so both the secrets and calculus one
tool that you can use to sort of well
here take a problem that is insoluble
and just sort of simplify down now in
just the same way as in trigonometry
identities can also be used and get
polynomials so here is an example if we
have a look at this disaster okay if the
first thing I asked you to do was hey
keep you up
you like factorize or find the roots of
this kind of thing you would write a
look at that and think really now as I
as you'll discover in a minute this is
actually not too difficult this can be
done through some judicious use of the
factor theorem okay yes in fact there
are some very obvious roots because when
I try to make D record but what I'm
gonna show you is how I didn't ease can
take this color it's still it's still
long to do is to factor theorem and just
break it down to size okay so this is
actually just the first half of the
question the second half is expressed
this as a quadratic in
this polynomial and hits find its zeros
right and hits find its
and yes now how do we really do this
okay first they have a look like good
interpret what is the question asking
what we say oh I chord right again X we
mean it's about an x squared and a
single a linear X term and a constant
sir right if I say a quadratic in sorry
what we're being something like this is
plus well I'll use my favorite quadratic
but the phobia is that that has no
solutions in this case I'm gonna say
that's a quadratic in sign okay because
I've got my science wait I've got my
Lumia sorry for such a things is my
constant F so a quadratic is this mates
aha
this squared plus a linear amount of
that plus a constant and that would be
my identity for how to write the P of X
okay so here's the way we're going to
begin what is a quadratic and that was
just they did okay I wonder what is that
P of X is exactly equal to for all
values of X that's what the equation by
quadratic in this every quadratic is in
the form a whatever squared plus B times
whatever plus C that's a general
quadratic in extra possible carriers
okay and the reason why this works is
because if you take this term here
you're going to get your power fall out
of that so this is this is gonna work
out when I have a look at this
immediately there's some things I can do
to make this easier
right cuz I want this quadratic but I've
got all of these underlings in here I've
got four of them right a B C and can I
know what any of the month so what's the
easiest one to have a look at anything
yeah okay I could expand before I
explain I think there are two of the
credit rules that are very easy seated
senton
okay so if I sub in X equal zero that's
going to give me a constant term is it
not and you can see here all of these
zeros all these years all these years
haha there is so right off the bat I can
say by comparison two coefficients
because the original quartic and this
new I didn't even have introduced there
should be exactly the same
I'm simply going to say C equals
negative eight I get that from comparing
the closet oh okay
that's good that's easy are there any
other of the Purdue rules that I could
find really easily okay you've got so
many great methods that we're going to
use but I think we can get easier ones
first anyone I think the leading
coefficient right because the leading
coefficient is here the great thing
about the leading one the world the
reason why we keep on going after is
because there's only one way out of any
expansion to get the leading coefficient
right like say the executor it's gonna
like be something tough missing here the
x squared term it's gonna have some of
this and it's also gonna have that guy
as well so they'll be intertwined so
I'll get to them but I might as well get
the ones where there's only one way
you're gonna give X before edges it only
comes from there do you agree so
therefore I can say whose it is
I can say a is equal to okay it's pretty
good right now it starts to get a little
more involved where would you go next
what you reckon so next sort of
direction to go
let me write out what we know so far
right just to keep you on ice I've got
this okay
so you have a look at this right clearly
I'm gonna now now I don't really have
much choice
I need to do some expansion do you agree
with that I've got to explain something
okay
and then I can actually compare some
proper coefficients it's all tangled up
in there okay so we better expand this
thing out should we do that to go just I
haven't done any collection of like
terms I have simply taken this guy and
expanded it do you see it's the first
three terms you see I think this guy
okay now we took care of the constants
we took care of the UM the X to the four
term okay now you have a look what else
is easy being an easy target is there's
only one X cubed term do you see it
there is no other excuse and so without
executors and this executors
they must be analogous to each other
right so again my comparison of
coefficients I can stay there for two K
equals negative six do you agree with
that you see where I got it from so
there's my value of okay that's good
I've got an egg see okay what's left
this is this guy over here right so if i
factor out my which where should I take
it
should I get it from here or should I
get it from here what do you think
clearly it's easier to go with this guy
right do you see why like I mean I could
get it out of my bag look do I wanna
peek to terms or one this makes a super
easy comparison right so you're gonna
stick you kid because of you so quick
bkx is exactly equivalent to six right
and in fact I already know what K is
right so I'm gonna write that as minus
3b equals six so B is equal to now just
think about what we did there for a
second right we went through that how we
went through in a kind of unusual order
almost a random well but it wasn't right
at all right we were trying to go for
low-hanging fruit right if you don't
want to say B first you're still getting
it will just take you four or five more
bites cuz you know less about it does
that make sense so you go for things
it's like wow that's just standing right
there all right yes if it's not money
then you're gonna have to go through a
bit more detail in Tommy sizes you can
see I have no citations here and that's
because of the simplicity okay now what
was her finding on ABC okay what was the
point so that I can express this thing
as a quadratic right so therefore I can
say P of X is exactly equal to now keep
in mind I actually know what K is don't
I
it's negative three so I'm gonna write
it like that I don't need to write plus
KX anymore that things being squared
then I've got what have I got - two
- - lots of that guy and then I've got -
a payment off on the end now at this
point again I have a bit of a choice
don't write this down because I don't
think you'll need to buy wait we see
this like in like ten we saw called
rainy guidance because that's kind of
this is an equation reducible to a
quadratic I would say we do better
substitute right side say let u equal x
squared minus 3x and then you get this
guy right - agree with that I have just
done a straight-up student and then you
look at this and the whole point of
writing like this is just to make the
factorization more obvious what is the
factorization by the small plus - do you
agree that that's fine okay however
there's no reason why just like in chain
rule you start off doing let u equals
this and then you start working with
that you use the chain rule formally but
there's no reason we have to do that
once you're comfortable - chain rule you
just start doing chain rules anyway and
I'm gonna do exactly the same thing here
I know what u is it's not mysterious
right so I'm gonna go straight to this
step but I'm just going to replace U
with the actual function there is U
minus four and there is U plus two and
you can see what looks very intuitive
for the beginning now is quite trivial
right there's a pair of properity and
they are both very easy to factorize
what's the first parents -
and the next one looks like s minus one
- that's okay in fact you'd be
hard-pressed to find any massive numbers
back I'm quite a lot to be questioned
her life was my decision not to be
confused with solving there's nothing to
solve me off right like this thing is
not equal to anything it's just a
polynomial but I can find the values
that make it zero and that I can solve
okay therefore the zeros are student in
order shall we
negative one one two and so just review
for a second what did we do we didn't
know what it meant to say a quadratic in
that okay and you're gonna encounter
this quite a lot then you just use
refined palette so you get quadratics
and X cubes weeks whatever it's okay
once you put it down this is a very
familiar kind of problem the hardest
thing is just being efficient than that
it's like this is a very minimal amount
of action would be if you know what you
would have to go through it and then
pray to your factorization or done X
quit okay except you think it's given or
do you make it okay so the answer is
both yes or no right so you'll notice
for example in earlier questions you
would get given an actual number in
place of K you can see here this is an
actual K that can be found right it must
be a certain value in some ways B
therefore I have to find it okay but you
will certainly be given something in
which to reform it like anyone just say
make it a quadratic in
they could give you a bit of a nudge
because at the moment we don't have
close to be quite that means find out
could you have just gone it's not from
the original
could we get this added x squared minus
X Widow and you are going to give me the
yes yes so you get extra person and then
you have two of them and collect the
like terms
is this what you say plus 8x my OS X and
then you would have a negative of the
original so you have x squared minus one
L bracket of XY minus six x over 2 yeah
might be expressing it as if you got to
this point then yes that's a quadratic
in the form y equals KX cetera it's a
bit of a roundabout way of doing it but
you get there you get there this is a
point of mind though I don't know if
excuse me if doing that would actually
led you straight here
here we come here and this is not this